sherry and alika ashuri the wife and
daughter of anushay azuri who was also
released by iranian authorities today
and is on his way home to the uk
ladies how are you feeling today such
big big news for your family
it's been very surreal um i mean we have
been waiting for this moment for about
five years now and
you know my dad has not seen the light
of day for for that long and tonight
we're happy that he will be reunited
with us and finally be able to sleep uh
in a comfortable bed and with his family
i interviewed i think a year or so ago
dominic wagon here in your garden and at
the time you were very very worried um
about tunisia and you were because he
had smuggled out a recording where he
sounded just so unlike himself you're
saying he's a very cheerful positive man
when he went into jail and he sounded
really dejected are you worried by
what he's going to be like
when he comes back or do you think he's
got the strength of character to have
kind of gone through this and come out
the other end
uh i think if he had the strength of
character to survive uh five years of
being unjustly
you know uh
imprisoned uh for you know all the time
that he was innocent and actually
managed to get through it with his
sanity fairly intact
i think he will
uh try his best to adjust to everyday
life afterwards and of course he'll have
our love and support all the way um i i
think he's just so he's over the moon
that you know he's so relieved he's so
happy that he's coming back he didn't
believe it believe it even until the
last minute
and eleka it is a day for celebrations
but there were times during this five
years that you were concerned that the
government were perhaps forgetting your
father and his plight
yes for us it's been you know a
particularly difficult battle to get his
name
in the news despite campaigning very
hard
for this to happen you know so many
things um were factored in
that you know wouldn't get name up there
as much and um
at the moment i feel like all of that is
behind us and that you know despite all
the obstacles that we faced we finally
reached this day through campaigning and
through his own sacrifices because he
he did sacrifice his health his safety
to send out recordings from prison
through covet to
you know display the horrible conditions
that were happening in prison he sent
recordings afterwards begging you know
boris johnson and the foreign
ministry to help him and the other
prisoners and he's campaigned for
everyone who is detained there so i
think the sacrifices have paid off and
you know
we can't
undo what's been done but we
have learned a lot from this we've grown
from this and hopefully we're going to
use that now to
to campaign and help
everyone else that's been um
behind you know left behind in iran or
for any future families that this might
happen to to may be able to prevent it
it's fantastic news and it's great to
share your relief and your celebration
that's him coming home
what kind of man is he and and is he
someone who will be
campaigning for those he's left behind
will you be as well or do you want to
just draw a line under it because of
course there are lots of other well
there are a number of other iranian
british nationals and others who are
incarcerated still we don't know their
names they haven't done what you've done
to campaign to get them out their
families
but there are a lot left aren't there
who are still languishing in jail
there are not just british other
nationalities as well obviously
uh i'm i'm
beyond 100
certain that once initiate goes through
a brief period of recuperating and
actually finding himself
and uh adjusting to everyday life even i
mean you can imagine even social media
you know internet changes over the past
years have been great once he adjusts
himself he will go
full force into campaigning for others
and
trying to help those left behind as you
said most definitely yeah and not only
him like we have made very strong
connections with the families of the
other detainees so uh we feel like it's
our responsibility
to
be their voice because uh we have
succeeded in our journey but there are
people who are still where we were
yesterday and they don't know how long
they're going to be
on that journey of suffering and
frustration so we would do our utmost to
help those people as well because they
are our friends at the end of the day
and looking forward to your
recovery as a family what does that look
like for you in the days and the weeks
that follow
honestly we've missed doing so many
ordinary things together you know we've
missed birthdays we've missed
christmases
we've missed walking the dog uh taking a
simple holiday
you know sitting together drinking a cup
of coffee just walking hand in hand
walking in our local park
all of this
is is we have to start all over again
we have to pick up life where it was
left off very
abruptly
and
just try and
try and find a semblance of the life
that
we had sort of been unhired us from for
the past five years
and and sherry just very briefly what
did you feel when you saw those pictures
of your husband touching down in muskats
um how does it make you feel
honestly i i think even until then i
couldn't quite
get my head around the fact that he was
he was flying and he was on his way here
there have been so many obstacles that
uh your mind puts this that you put you
have this mental break on you don't want
to admit to yourself that it's happening
but i think as we get closer to the time
that they land it's sinking in more and
more and uh
it's
overwhelming it's uh it's it's very
difficult to describe
okay
very deep joy yeah sherry and ali kazuri
thank you so much for
joining us on sky news and donek wagon
thank you for your insights as well
today